♪ ♪
SPEED TO DEVELOPMENTS TONIGHT ON
OUR QUEST FOR EQUAL JUSTICE
AND ALL THOSE THAT ABUSE POWER
ARE ACCOUNTABLE.
LET ME GIVE YOU A HEADLINE.
THERE'S A LOT OF NEWS COMING
THIS WEEK THAT I KNOW OF.
SO STAY TUNED.
BUT ACCORDING TO JUST RELEASED
REPORTS, A FEDERAL COURT NOW HAS
ORDERED A HEARING ABOUT WHETHER
TO SPEED UP THE RELEASE OF
DOCUMENTS.
HAS NOW OBTAINED THE OBAMA
IMMUNITY AGREEMENT, CHERYL
MILLS, HEATHER SAMUELSON.
PAY ATTENTION.
I'M NOT MAKING THIS UP.
"TO DISPOSE OF EVIDENCE AND
REFUSED TO COMPLY WITH FEDERAL
LAW.
HE IS THE PROSECUTOR FROM
MASSACHUSETTS.
HE IS ZEROING IN ON WHY CERTAIN
PIECES OF MATERIAL MAY HAVE BEEN
WITHHELD FROM THE REPORT AS IT
PERTAINS TO SPINE ON THE TEAM OF
TRUMP.
AUTHOR OF THE ACL JAY.
LET'S START WITH, HANG ON A
SECOND.
I'VE NEVER HEARD, EXCEPT FOR
THEM DESTROYING PHONES, WHICH
MUELLER DID.
I'VE NEVER HEARD OF THE
ATTORNEYS IN THE CASE WHERE WE
KNOW THAT SHE HAD THESE EMAILS,
JORDAN.
WE KNOW THAT SHE ALSO DELETED
THE SUBPOENAED EMAILS.
I NEVER HEARD OF ALLOWING THE
DESTRUCTION OF EVIDENCE AND
THOSE TWO LAWYERS SAT IN WHEN
SHE WAS BEING INTERROGATED BY
THE FBI.
DID EITHER OF YOU EVER HEAR THAT
BEFORE?
>> FIRST, THEY WERE AIDES TO
HILLARY CLINTON.
CHERYL MILLS WAS HER CHIEF OF
STAFF.
SAMUELSON WAS HER WHITE HOUSE
LIAISON FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE AND THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
THEY BECOME HER PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS.
THEY TAKE OVER THESE EMAILS.
EACH ONE HAD ONE.
THESE WERE THE BACKUPS TO THE
INFAMOUS SERVER OUT IN COLORADO
THAT HAD 62,000 EMAILS ON THEM.
EACH HAD IT.
GUESS WHAT, EACH WAS GOING
THROUGH AND DELETING EMAILS,
SEAN.
THEY WANTED TO MAKE SURE RIGHT
OFF THE BAT THAT THEY WERE
IMMUNE FROM THE ESPIONAGE ACT,
THE CLASSIFIED INFORMATION ACT.
CRIMES THAT BRING PRISON TIME OF
UP TO 28 YEARS IF YOU COMBINE
THEM FOR EACH OF THESE.
YET, THEY GET FULL IMMUNITY.
BUT NOT JUST THAT, THEY ALSO GET
THE FBI TO AGREE TO NOT ALLOW
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO ACCESS
THIS INFORMATION ON THEIR
COMPUTERS VIA FOIA.
WE'VE GOT THAT RIGHT THERE
DOMINIC.
IN THE CLINTON TEAM.
>> Sean: OBVIOUSLY, THAT WOULD
NEVER HAPPEN FOR TEAM TRUMP.
TOM, JUDICIAL WATCH.
THE HEARINGS ABOUT WHETHER TO
SPEED UP THE DOCUMENT RELEASE.
NOW WE HAVE A LOT OF THE TEXT
MESSAGES, BUT THEY KEEP
DRIBBLING OUT MORE AND MORE AND
YOU KEEP GETTING THEM.
HOW MUCH MORE DO WE THINK IS
THE?
>> OH, THERE'S 13,000 MORE PAGE
PAGES.
IN THE FBI IS TAKING THE
POSITION THAT THEY GENERALLY
SHOULDN'T HAVE TO TURN OVER TEXT
MESSAGES.
SO WE DON'T KNOW WHAT TEXT
MESSAGES ARE BEING WITHHELD.
THE COURT HAS LOOKED AT THE
PRODUCTION SCHEDULE.
THERE'S BEEN 20,000 RECORDS
GENERALLY OVER THE LAST YEAR AND
A HALF.
THEY'VE ONLY PRODUCED OR
PROCESSED 500 PER MONTH.
ABOUT 6,000.
SO HE'S LOOKING AT SCENE 13,000
RECORDS BEING PRODUCED.
HE WANTS TO HAVE A COURT HEARING
TO TAKE ANOTHER LOOK TO SEE